consideramos el mercado para las bolsas
de plástico bolsas de plástico
y estoy eligiendo este mercado en
particular porque puedan existir algunos
costos asociados con estas bolsas de
plástico que no se consideran cuando
estamos viendo el punto de vista de los
proveedores y de los consumidores para
que tenemos nuestra curva de demanda
obviamente la demanda viene de los
supermercados
esa es la curva de demanda y también la
podemos ver como el beneficio marginal
por lo que nuestra primera bolsa esta
primera bolsa que producimos tiene un
gran beneficio marginal los mercados
quieren tenerla ya que se le pueden dar
a sus clientes los que compran ahí para
llevar sus compras a casa pero cada
bolsa incremental posterior va a
disminuir el beneficio marginal por lo
que esta curva va bajando y esta curva
verde de acá eso ya lo hemos visto
varias veces es nuestra curva de oferta
curva de oferta que podemos ver como
nuestra curva de el costo marginal el
costo de producir esta primera bolsa el
costo de oportunidad
vemos que fue de un centavo por bolsa y
después fue aumentando y aumentando
conforme producimos más bolsas y tenemos
un precio de equilibrio y una cantidad
de equilibrio la cantidad de equilibrio
parece que está en 3.5 millones de
bolsas por semana y el precio de
equilibrio está más o menos en dos
centavos por bolsa
esos fueron si éstos fueran los únicos
costos y todos los beneficios entonces
esta área de acá mostraría el beneficio
agregado total de este ecosistema de
aquí de la oferta y la demanda que los
clientes de estos supermercados están
obteniendo al realizarse esta
transacción el beneficio marginal es
mayor que el costo marginal por lo que
toda esta área va a ser nuestro
superávit y ya lo hemos visto en varias
ocasiones pero ahora pensemos en los
costos agregados que tienen en
particular las bolsas de plástico pero
que no se encuentran ubicadas en los
costos ni en los precios las bolsas de
plástico tienen una externalidad
negativa externalidad negativa
hay un costo asociado es negativo porque
es un costo que está asociado con estas
bolsas de plástico y en este ejemplo
este costo no está asociado a nuestro
costo marginal también podríamos llegar
a tener externalidades positivas por
ejemplo las relacionadas con plantar
árboles o cosas similares que dan un
beneficio para la sociedad en el caso de
las externalidades negativas como las
que están asociadas a las bolsas de
plástico es que estas bolsas van a ser
desechadas van a estar tiradas en las
calles la ciudad se tiene que encargar
de limpiarlas también hay riesgos
ambientales los animales podrían
intentar comerlas y ahogarse si está
llegando al mar algunos animales podrían
enredarse con ellas y ahogarse así pues
nos contratamos algunos expertos que
esto no es cosa sencilla pero esos
expertos determinan que las
externalidades negativas de estas bolsas
de plástico son de los centavos por
bolsa le cuesta a la sociedad y al
ambiente por encima del costo marginal
correspondiente a los productores dos
centavos por bolsa ahora conociendo esto
y asumiendo que este enunciado es
correcto que no es algo sencillo de
hacer pero asumiendo que es correcto
cuál sería la cantidad óptima de bolsas
a comprar y también en cuál sería la
cantidad óptima de bolsas a producir y
qué es lo que hacemos cuando se produce
esta cantidad y para ayudarnos a pensar
en ello vamos a crear una nueva curva
ese es el costo marginal de los
productores ahora vamos a tener una
curva que sea la del costo marginal de
los productores más la de la sociedad
para la producción de la primera bolsa
el costo de oportunidad es de un centavo
pero para la sociedad esto cuesta otros
dos centavos adicionales por lo que el
costo de oportunidad ahora es de 3
centavos podemos dibujar otra curva que
podemos ver como el costo marginal del
productor y de la sociedad costo
marginal del productor y de la sociedad
y ahora podemos pensar las cosas en
términos de un beneficio total un
beneficio neto total la primera bolsa
que compra el supermercado va a tener
más de 5 centavos de ganancia pero no si
pensamos en el beneficio neto hacia la
social
no va a tener toda esa altura de acá
solo va a tener esta parte de acá eso
que soy señalando la línea que está
entre el 5 y el 3 podríamos decir que es
el beneficio neto marginal ya que
tomamos el beneficio marginal y le
quitamos el total del costo marginal
incluyendo las externalidades para la
siguiente bolsa el beneficio va a ser un
poco menor porque se va a incrementar el
costo y así sucesivamente y eso tiene
sentido para la sociedad que seguirá
recibiendo beneficio de esto y si
pensamos en todo el ecosistema que va a
seguir recibiendo beneficio hasta que
lleguemos hasta este otro punto de
equilibrio que está acá una vez que
pasamos a ese punto de equilibrio
pensando globalmente considerando el
medio ambiente el gobierno y todo esto
de pronto el costo marginal de cada
unidad incremental va a ser mayor que el
beneficio marginal si queremos producir
más allá de este punto vamos a estar
incurriendo en costos estamos
consumiendo nuestros beneficios y si lo
produjéramos hasta nuestro viejo punto
de equilibrio más o menos podríamos ver
que el área púrpura es mayor que el área
amarilla estaríamos obteniendo un
beneficio total negativo para las
no lo habíamos visualizado de esta
manera antes es poco usual para nosotros
encontrarnos una pérdida de este lado de
la curva o de este lado del punto de
equilibrio pero también lo podemos ver
así esto de aquí es un beneficio total
negativo o un superávit negativo
superávit negativo lo que se quiere como
un conjunto como un todo desde el punto
de vista del gobernante benévolo es
tomar en consideración todos los costos
y todos los beneficios de las bolsas de
plástico la situación ideal si se quiere
optimizar el beneficio en la sociedad se
quisiera que el precio de equilibrio
estuviera más o menos por acá a tres
centavos y medio con una cantidad de
equilibrada de más o menos 1.8 millones
procurando evitar esta cantidad que no
queremos que es pura perdida y que es
menos eficiente para la sociedad